and I was raised by this funny mom that
loves to make box cake and I was raised
by grandmothers and they make frosting
one way and honestly that is the way
that I we make frosting today we don't
make boiled frosting we don't make
anything other than this frosting and
it's really simple and it's really easy
to and alter the flavors of it it's
butter unsalted European style butter
its confectioner sugar we paddle those
two suckers together until the butter
has broken down and we're going to make
this frosting in a coffee frosting and
when we are creating recipes and we're
trying to figure out what what we want
what flavor we want in what vehicle so
in this case coffee into a frosting we
have so many decisions we have to think
about one what kind of what type of
frosting do we want to make it never ly
comes back to this very simple style of
frosting and how are we going to get the
flavor is so when you think about coffee
it's like okay we could do this I could
skin this cat so many different ways I
can just had coffee and but coffee is
largely water based so it's going to
alter my volume it's going to plummet in
volume or abruption not good and it's
going to separate it's not going to
emulsify there's not good no one wants a
nun emulsified frosting please give me
one more special yeah and I can add
espresso espresso work this press is a
little bit bitter and I don't know I
don't want it to taste like espresso I
wanted to taste like coffee and I could
what else could I do I could like melt
the butter and try and brew coffee
through it or try and like do a pour
over with coffee I mean I start going in
all these places of like okay how can I
do it
we tested so many different recipes for
coffee frosting and we ended up taking
whole milk
instant coffee
and some kosher salt and and the instant
coffee really allows you to get a depth
of flavor in there without and having to
add too much milk you can really really
control the depth of flavor again the
depth against the amount of milk that
you're adding in now the hardest part
about creating something is it's really
easy to dream up an idea but it's really
hard to make it into make it into a
reality and I'm going to let you finish
while I talk okay and and the hardest
part about something like this coffee
frosting is I know I need to add coffee
in some in some degree the instant
coffee really needs the milk to dissolve
itself right we don't like I mean maybe
some of you instant coffee granules but
I don't I want it to be smooth and I
wanted to have the flavor of coffee so I
can't just peddle instant coffee into my
butter I need enough liquid to hydrate
that instant coffee into a coffee flavor
but I also know that I only have a
certain allowance for the amount of
liquid that I can add into this frosting
before it breaks and it separates and
this coffee frosting like literally
comes right up to the line in terms of
keeping that emulsification intact and
separating separating it out and that is
the hardest part of the job where it's
like knowing when to say when I wish
that more of us took and these classes
to be able to sort of do to be able to
really calculate the math and understand
we understand why it's happening we'll
understand how it's happening but
sometimes we don't understand what the
like what's a very very very very very
and what the tipping point is and what
amount we can add before it tips over
and so on and that's the coolest part of
the job too is sort of getting to learn
about the scientific process through
something as simple like I want to make
a coffee frosting but it needs to be
able to be smooth enough to spread